as you all know today there has been a
shocking and tragic series of events
which has led to the lives of three
innocent people being taken
and left another member of the public in
a critical condition in hospital
my thoughts are with all the families
affected by this horrific incident and
we are working extremely hard to try and
understand exactly what's happened
I can tell you that a 31 year old man
has been arrested on suspicion of murder
and remains in police custody
we are not looking for anyone else in
connection with the attacks and I can
reassure the public that it is safe to
visit the city center
there may be some road restrictions in
place as we continue to establish
exactly what's happened
police were called to Wilkinson Road
just after 4am after a member of the
public reported that two people age 19
had been stabbed and were unresponsive
we had a further call to another
incident in Milton Street
where the driver of a stolen van had
attempted to run over three people
as a result
one man is in hospital in a critical
condition
while two others are believed to have
suffered minor injuries
the van was then stopped on Maple Street
where a man was tasered and detained by
police officers on suspicion of murder
a man in his 50s was also found dead
from knife injuries in magdala Road by a
member of the public
at the moment we believe that the
suspect has stolen this man's vehicle
and driven it to Milton Street where he
is then driven at members of the public
we are still in the early stages of the
investigation and need to determine
exactly what the motives were behind
this attack
[Applause]
we are keeping an open mind and are
working closely with counter-terrorism
policing to establish the facts as we
would normally do in this type of
circumstances
the families of all the victims have
been informed and are being supported by
specially trained officers
officers have also carried out a number
of searches at addresses across the city
to gather evidence
but no further arrests have been made
team of dedicated detectives are
investigating the circumstances
surrounding the incident and will
continue to gather evidence over the
coming days
I want to thank those who live and work
in our city for their patience and
understanding in incredibly difficult
circumstances we will of course keep the
public updated as soon as we're able to
say anything further
this is a very sad day for our city
and we will do everything possible to
get Justice for the victims and their
families
thank you